I'm here with the renowned SE Cupp after
her appearance on real time tonight in
which you were terrific I thought it was
a good way you were great and it was
good it was good show as well sorry if I
disagree
I understand you've got some tweet hate
yeah always but this night was
particularly good oh it's yourself this
is having fun this is from at coach
kitty oh why the F does SE Cupp we're
honest sort of sorority ama she Dowager
stuff on your show it distracts me from
her nonsense oh wait
Wow so yeah fit and then from @j yelling
I couldn't dislike a c-cup any more what
a windbag how about you go away as he
cup how about that I'm really gonna do
that that cup Dame has nope he's fancy
that cup Dame has no clue as to why she
is a Republican
the tent is closed to her oh wow
there's a fictional tent that you're not
part of it
this is room Ernesto El Capitan he's
usually very hot very um please tell the
Omar that I seek up is the most
deadweight guest he keeps bringing back
hash tag just saying yeah this is a lot
of just same exact thing wow this is a
good one for me and my good friend
Alicia Menendez oh good
I hope Tamara's in a hot tub somewhere
right now with Alicia Menendez and SE
Cupp smoking a joint send pics please
and a little bit of really creepy love
then we'll let you know where the night
ends this is at princess so much dears
Omar every time I see covers on real
time my ears bleed and my brain hurts
listening to the BS
please stop having her on the panel that
could be taking a lot of unnecessary
maybe you have been ear infection in the
mirror maybe you have a brain disease
and her ears needed to blue then you
helped her it wasn't me it wasn't you is
that the worst of it those are pretty
bad yeah it's a good night though I mean
honestly I think though I see come
please